dr lorraine murphy is an associate
professor
of english at hillsdale college where
she has taught for the past
10 years a recipient of the emily
doherty award for teaching excellence
she teaches courses in realism the 18th
century novel
and jane austen she serves as faculty
advisor
to the kravitz and blue stockings
regency appreciation club
and as secretary for the phi kappa phi
honor society
she taught a hillsdale college online
course
titled the young jane austen northanger
abbey
which is available at
online.hillsdale.edu
please join me in welcoming dr murphy
[Applause]
thank you grace and i'd also like to
thank doug jeffrey
and matt bell for inviting me to speak
and all of you for being here to listen
that her novels have been so repeatedly
and successfully adapted to film
tells us something of austin's skill in
scripting plot and character
but one thing a film cannot give you is
the voice of the narrator
i'd like to open tonight with a passage
from emma
that i believe reveals something
essential about austin's particular
genius
emma in this passage has accompanied her
protege harriet
to the general store in highbury
harriet tempted by everything and swayed
by half a word
was always very long at a purchase and
while she was still hanging over muslins
and changing her mind emma went to the
door for amusement
much could not be hoped from the traffic
of even the busiest part of highbury
mr perry walking hastily by mr william
cox letting himself
in at the office door mr cole's carriage
horses returning from exercise
or a stray letter boy on an obstinate
mule
were the liveliest objects she could
presume to expect
and when her eyes fell only on the
butcher with his tray
a tidy old woman traveling homewards
from shop with her full basket
two crews curling over a dirty bone in a
string of dawdling children
around the baker's little bow window
eyeing the gingerbread
she knew she had no reason to complain
and was amused enough
quite enough still to stand at the door
a mind lively and at ease can do with
seeing nothing
and can see nothing that does not answer
this i suggest is the secret to austin's
art
gratefully secure in a mundane setting
where others might
see nothing of interest jane austen
could do with seeing nothing her lively
mind could discern
and articulate the meaning in a series
of commonplace actions
that would not answer to a more callous
observer
by addressing her attention to an
ordinary scene such as this
austin gives it a voice the most
everyday materials are rendered eloquent
by her precise and affectionate language
it's my privilege this evening to talk
about austin's life
with the aim of understanding how it
nurtured her talent
and my thesis is this that her life and
work were fueled by a passionate
or in the words of g.k chesterton an
exuberant
interest in the ordinary
jane austen's natural exuberance is
enriched over the course of her life
by a network of love and friendship that
brings her into contact with
every variety of anticipation
disappointment
uncertainty loss hope laughter
and joy we can know perhaps her natural
reserve with strangers
as well as the unpredictable nature of
some relationships
encouraged that close scrutiny of the
minutia of our social behavior
that is a hallmark of her fiction and a
large part of what makes it so filmable
her exuberant spirit is somewhat
chastened by a prolonged period of
hardship
and the awareness of her dependent
position in society
yet the sense of joyful possibility
remains from first to last
ever expressed in her work with a
mozartian fluency
in the resources of the english language
she is unfailingly precise
and funny and real
she was born december excuse me december
7
16 1775
seventh of her parents ate children the
austins were not
financially prosperous but they were
hard working
energetic and busy and theirs was a home
where the written word was
celebrated jane's father the reverend
george austin served as rector of the
church of saint nicholas
seen here in the small village of
steventon county of hampshire
southwest of london
here you see the church door framed by
carvings not of saints or angels but of
a man's face
and a woman's reverend austin
farmed in his spare time ran a boy's
boarding school
out of their crowded home seen here and
collected a library of some 500 volumes
that jane was free to borrow from
as she pleased his wife cassandra
in addition to her duties as mother
school mistress
head gardener and manager of the dairy
and poultry yards
still found time to write witty poems
for special occasions
and jane's older brothers published a
periodical
and supervised the staging of plays when
family and friends gathered at their
parsonage
for the holidays
the children would have no inheritance
to speak of
from their parents indeed reverend
austin and his wife spent several years
digging their way out of
debt on a very small income
their eldest son james took a degree at
oxford and became a clergyman
inheriting his father's post at
steventon when he retired
the next son george suffered an
unspecified
disability perhaps a seizure disorder or
perhaps cerebral palsy
but he lived a long and otherwise
healthy life in the care of a family
in a neighboring village the third
brother edward
was adopted at the age of 12 by distant
relations who were very wealthy and
childless he remained close with his
parents and siblings
and came to play a pivotal role in
jane's life
but financially and socially his
adoption
removed him to another sphere
henry was the most gregarious austin and
followed
several professions including army
officer
banker and clergyman in the course of
his interesting life
francis and charles the two youngest
boys pursued careers in the navy
francis rising to the rank of admiral
finally little cassandra was like a
second mother
to her younger sister jane mrs austin
remarked
if cassandra's head had been going to be
cut off jane would have hers cut off too
jane's formal schooling was brief and
perhaps blessedly so as
girls schools could be a breeding ground
for infections
that were too often fatal she made a
narrow escape from a serious illness
after being sent away to school at the
age of seven
returned safely home she mastered
needlework which was a vital part
of her contribution to the household
economy
and enjoyed piano cassandra studied
drawing
her father must have encouraged jane to
enjoy his library
and her brothers must have brought new
publications home on a regular basis
for by the time she began writing
fiction at 12 or 13
she was familiar with the classics of
the earlier 18th century
the essays of samuel johnson and the
novels of samuel richardson
as well as more contemporary novels by
charlotte lennox fannie bernie mariah
edgeworth
and anne radcliffe
three leather-bound notebooks were her
first prize possessions
the second is inscribed a gift from my
father
and the third is inscribed in the hand
of reverend dawson himself
who praises his daughter's stories as
effusions of fancy by a very young lady
consisting of tales in a style entirely
new
one of the longer stories in the second
notebook is dated june
1790 when jane was 14.
her first notebook was by then already
full
her practice was to draft on scrap paper
and then transcribe her stories into the
notebooks when she considered them ready
so to speak for publication
individual stories were dedicated to
various friends and family members
and the notebooks were passed around in
the austin circle
in the manner of published books it
sounds very serious and it is
but the stories themselves are full of
hilarity
young jane delights in satire and in
particular she enjoys
sending up the emotional excess that was
characteristic of popular fiction at the
time
in a story in the epistolary style
composed as a series of letters
that jane wrote at 14 she gives us the
following
with her protagonist laura writing to a
younger woman
marianne
convinced as you must be from what i
have already told you concerning
augustus and sophia
that there never were a happier couple i
need not i imagine
inform you that their union had been
contrary to the inclinations of their
cruel
and mercenary parents who had vainly
endeavored with
obstinate perseverance to force them
into a marriage with those whom they had
ever abhorred
but within heroic fortitude worthy to be
related and admired
they had both constantly refused to
submit to such despotic power
after having so nobly disentangled
themselves from the shackles of parental
authority
by a clandestine marriage they were
determined never to forfeit the good
opinion they had gained in the world
in so doing by accepting any proposals
of reconciliation that might be offered
them
by their fathers to this farther trial
of their noble independence however
they were never exposed
she further displays her mastery of
satire in the history of england
by a partial prejudiced and ignorant
historian
in which she imitates the dry narration
of gibbon and goldsmith
and includes a running joke on her
fidelity to mary queen of scots
here she gives us the reign of edward vi
son of henry viii
as this prince was only nine years old
at the time of his father's death
he was considered by many people as too
young to govern
and the late king happening to be of the
same opinion
his mother's brother the duke of
somerset was chosen protector of the
realm
during his minority the duke was
beheaded
of which he might with reason have been
proud had he known that such was the
death of mary queen of scotland
but as it was impossible that he should
be conscious of what had never happened
it does not appear that he felt
particularly delighted with the manner
of it
the use of humor to probe the darker
side of human behavior from a safe
distance
is perfected in a complete novella
austin wrote
probably in 1794 when she would have
been
18 years old titled lady susan
it's in the epistolary form and features
a smart
manipulative almost a moral protagonist
a widow and mother who uses charm and a
thorough mastery of social conventions
to get on in the world cheerfully
disrupting and privately laughing
at the dull but well-meaning people who
come in her way
this is the story with stillman adapted
as love and friendship
the film we're screening tomorrow and
and i can assure you that it's something
very delightful
the story's power derives from the
charisma of lady susan herself
but also from the exposure of mannered
behavior
as a resource that while ostensibly
designed to convey respect and deference
can be deployed for completely
self-serving ends
and this i think is an insight that
propels jane austen
into the world of her mature fiction
the very next year 1795
she began to draft the novel that would
many years later
become her first published work sense
insensibility
then titled eleanor and marianne it's a
study among other things
of the value of suppressing emotion out
of consideration for others
eleanor dashwood is the opposite of lady
susan
in every respect but one that her
demeanor
does not reflect her true thoughts and
feelings
when we step into society we step into a
role
as eleanor knows too well
and marianne who can be nothing but
natural
and sincere suffers greatly in london
where willoughby is free
to politely rebuffer in english film
we rejoice that colonel brandon will
protect marianne
from that knowledge of the world that
might render her more mature
but less unspoiled
it's a story of two sisters in love and
for a brief time jane and cassandra
knew that happiness in 1795
cassandra had been engaged to tom fowle
a young clergyman with very little
income
for three years that autumn
tom agreed to sail to the west indies as
chaplain for a regiment of the british
militia
upon his return they would marry
cassandra spent that christmas holiday
with the fowl family in berkshire
to see tom off and the visit is the
occasion for our first surviving letter
from jane to her sister dated january
1796
when jane was just 20.
with the satiric humor that hardly
disguises a sense of
joyful anticipation jane refers to a
young man named
tom lefroy an irish cousin
of neighbors with whom the austins were
friendly
he's visiting hampshire on his way to
london and jane confesses that
she's danced with him repeatedly that
tom is being teased about his attachment
to her
and that she greatly enjoys his company
i'm almost afraid to tell you how my
irish friend and i behaved
she writes imagine to yourself
everything most profligate and shocking
in the way of dancing and sitting down
together
it's appropriate to pause here and say a
word about austin's letters
she wrote them to scores of friends and
relations but in particular
when she and cassandra were separated
jane wrote copiously
and often in a stream of consciousness
style
she records neighborhood news visits
given and received
the appearance or dress of this or that
person
the quality of a meal and she often
works out the cutting side of her wit
as if seizing an outlet for honest
thoughts
impossible to express in company in that
sense a picture of her character drawn
exclusively from her letters would be
woefully incomplete it's clear that
cassandra
burned precisely the more personal
missives
to protect her sister's privacy
claire tomlin whose biography of austin
i highly recommend
remarks of this letter to cassandra
the fact that the manuscript eleanor and
marianne was lying completed
somewhere in the house as she wrote
gives this first letter an added
resonance
it is the only surviving letter in which
jane is clearly writing
as the heroine of her own youthful story
living for herself the short period of
power
excitement and adventure that might come
to a young woman
when she was thinking of choosing a
husband
just for a brief time she is enacting
instead of imagining
we can't help knowing that her personal
story
will not go in the direction she is
imagining in the letter
that as it turned out it was not tom
lefroy
or anyone like him who became her
adventure
but the manuscript upstairs not marriage
but
art and in her art she made this short
period
in a young woman's life carry such wit
and human understanding
as few writers have managed to cram into
solemn volumes
three times the size
75 years later tom lefroy
told austin's nephew that he fell in
love with jane then
with a boyish love but he was expected
to study law
and work for his family's advancement
and he could not afford to marry a woman
who wouldn't bring him a penny
he later indeed became a judge and then
lord chief justice of ireland
amply fulfilling his family's trust and
expectation
so the relations with whom he was
staying whisked him away and took care
that he and jane did not cross
paths on his subsequent visits she never
saw him again
cassandra's fiance died of a fever in
santo domingo
in the spring of 1797 and though she was
still in her 20s
she never considered another marriage
jane on the other hand
did entertain that possibility but will
come to that in its place
how would jane austen have appeared to a
potential suitor
the descriptions of young men and women
in her novels are not terribly detailed
she focuses on height the manner of
movement
and the quality of expression that can
be found in the eyes
we know that cassandra was considered
the prettier of the two sisters
jane's brother henry said that had jane
been any taller she would have exceeded
the middle height
several relations describe her as either
slender
or spare her posture was upright
and her step was light and firm or quick
and decisive
her eyes were bright and her cheeks were
full of color
notably she is the only one of eight
siblings excepting her brother george
who never had a professional portrait of
any kind taken
the only image that survives that was
taken from the life
is this sketch with some watercolor
drawn by her sister cassandra
seen here though austin's niece anna
with whom she was close
later declared that this portrait was
hideously unlike her aunt jane
so she remains a bit of a mystery and
fittingly we meet her
in her language rather than any image
in the summer of 1796 reverend austin
made a decision
the first of two that would have
momentous consequences
for his daughter jane well clear of debt
and with their sons embarked on their
respective careers
he and his wife would cease taking
borders and running their home as a boys
school
this meant that the burden of cooking
serving and cleaning was greatly
lessened for the women of the fam
of the house and that jane had more
leisure to write
that autumn she began drafting first
impressions
the work later renamed pride and
prejudice within a year
she had polished that satisfaction and
took up eleanor and marianne
revising from the epistolary style to
third person
narration and i think this effort
shows the sense of a vocation and
something much more than the desire to
simply write for the amusement
of herself or her family in 1798 and 99
she wrote the novel later published as
northanger abbey then titled susan
and in november 1797 jane's father
possibly without her knowledge sent a
letter to one
thomas cadell a publisher in london
whose firm had printed the works of
gibbon and johnson
reverend austin wrote that he had a
manuscript for a novel in his possession
and would mr cadell consider bringing it
out at the author's expense
the publisher opened the letter wrote
declined by return of post
across the top and mailed it back
the fact that austin's father was one of
her most ardent admirers
makes it all the more poignant that his
well-deserved retirement
from the parish of stephenton brought
jane's writing life
to a decisive halt this
second and equally momentous decision
was announced to jane and cassandra
over the christmas holidays of 1800
by january 1801 plans to move to bath
were underway
jane's piano was now sold her father's
library was sold off too
her parents intended to enjoy the
crowded social calendar
theater dances card parties commonly
regarded as one of the prime attractions
of bath
and to take various forays to seaside
resorts
jane and her parents removed two
temporary lodgings that spring
while cassandra made a visit with
friends before joining them
and jane's letters from this time
reflect a struggle with low spirits
another stupid party last night she
wrote
one card table with six people to look
over and talk nonsense to each other
regarding their search for a home when
you arrive
we will at least have the pleasure of
examining some of these putrifying
houses again
they are so very desirable in size and
situation that there is some
satisfaction in spending 10 minutes
within
and the note of dejection is
unmistakable
cannot anyhow continue to find people
agreeable
this from a woman who could make a
cramped setting
or a trivial card game or a disagreeable
person
bristle with interest on the page in her
writing desk were manuscripts for three
complete novels but her words now dried
up
that jane was tempted by a marriage
proposal
in 1802 may reflect both her unhappiness
in bath
and her sense that her period of
creative fruitfulness was at an end
harris big wither was the younger
brother
of three sisters who were close lifelong
friends to jane and cassandra
he was five years jane's junior when he
proposed to her
just shortly before her 27th birthday
while she was visiting for the holidays
harris was the only son and heir to his
father's considerable estates
and as he would be wealthy in his own
right there was no need for any dowry on
her side
jane accepted his proposal and the
family celebrated the good news
but by early next morning she had packed
her bags
and asked to see harris again
we can't know what passed between them
other than that she withdrew her
acceptance and made arrangements to
leave
immediately did she determine that she
could not be happy in the absence of
romantic love
did she fear the risks associated with
bringing children into the world
was she unable to face the prospect of
giving up her writing for good
we can only speculate on the basis of
those of her heroines
who turn down offers of marriage
elizabeth bennett
who will not marry mr collins because in
the absence of deep respect and
affection they will not make one another
happy
fanny price turns down henry crawford
because she doubts his integrity of
character
and ann elliott who refuses charles
musgrove
because her heart still belongs to
another man
in january of 1805 the reverend austin
died peacefully in bath
for four years jane had carried her
manuscripts from place to place
packed in her writing desk as far as we
know she had attempted only one fragment
of a composition never pursued
true in 1803 she had achieved what might
be called her first professional success
by selling the manuscript of northanger
abbey
to the publisher richard crosby for ten
pounds
something like four hundred dollars in
our currency
but as crosby never printed her work
this was a somewhat discouraging success
as first successes go and now the austin
women
jane cassandra and their mother were
effectively homeless
they must forfeit the annuity reverend
austin had earned as part of his
retirement
they would live on whatever jane's
brothers together could provide them
with the interest that mrs austin and
cassandra earned on some
small investments jane had none
they sometimes stayed near relations in
bath but only in rented lodgings
they sometimes stayed with friends in
hampshire
and sometimes with jane's brother edward
at his largest date in kent
seen here but they never stayed any one
place very long
and they were always visitors or guests
this continued for another four years
making a gap of eight years in the
career of a young woman who began to
write at 12 or 14
and died at 41.
finally in 1809 edward austin owner of a
great deal of land and property
this estate and others realized there
were houses at his disposal
and that his mother and sisters might
like to stay in one
they chose a rather large brick home
situated at a crossroads
in shoton village in hampshire they had
a garden
to work at the back mrs austin was a
devoted gardener
and they spent time making clothes and
giving reading lessons to some of the
needier children in the village
jane's life was effectively transformed
the women agreed that jane would prepare
the family breakfast of tea and toast
she was typically the first to rise but
thereafter
the cooking gardening and general
housework would be overseen by her
sister and mother
and in moments of leisure jane could
write
she began immediately took the
manuscripts out of her writing desk
and set to revision her lively mind
set at ease by the security of a settled
home
could once again do with seeing nothing
and this ordinary nothing the nothing
special
of a daily routine that had been so long
denied her
could once again answer her
attentiveness
with the voice of inspiration
in 1810 she sold sense and sensibility
and saw her first work in print
the following year a commercial success
the achievement must have been all the
sweeter given how long she had waited
and from our perspective it's made
bittersweet
by the fact that austin would enjoy the
full exercise of her powers
for only five more years but as an
exuberant
and energetic writer she made them count
with one commercial success to her name
her publisher
thomas egerton was happy to purchase the
copyright
to pride and prejudice in november of
1812
jane describes lopping and cropping her
1797 manuscript
into the form so beloved by all her
admirers
elizabeth bennett never fails to charm
us with her intelligence
self-assurance and sense of humor and
fitzwilliam darcy is a man of reserve
whose warm and devoted nature is
gradually revealed
the drama turns on that moment when
elizabeth
overly trusting of her first impressions
is forced to revise her estimation of
wickham
of darcy and most especially of herself
but alongside that plot line runs
another
and related one that is i think easy to
overlook
and in fact our 1940 film version
of the of the novel uh elides this
though she's enlightened regarding
wickham's true history with the darcy
family
there are still depths to mr darcy's
character that elizabeth has not yet
plumbed
and so she still faces as we all must a
moment of decision
of faith and it is her instinctive
almost unthinking willingness
in the novel to trust mr darcy with her
sister's humiliating story
that actually allows him to rescue lydia
and the bennett families the bennett
family's reputation
jane spent the next two years drafting
her most ambitious work yet
mansfield park it is the work most
provocative
of differences among her fans and i've
not yet seen
a film that i believe does it justice
its heroine is fanny price one of nine
siblings born to
overwhelmed and far from prosperous
parents
but her mother's sister has married a
baronet and the bertram family
offered to adopt fannie as a way of
helping out
she grows into womanhood in outwardly
comfortable circumstances
but remains painfully shy physically
weak
and of a somewhat secondary status among
the bertrams
edmund the kindest of her cousins is her
only friend apart from her brother
william with whom she corresponds
devotedly
these illustrations from a late
victorian edition
might give you a sense of fannie's
somewhat passive demeanor
the settled way of life at mansfield
park is pleasantly
unsettled by the arrival in their
neighborhood of henry
and mary crawford a brother and sister
raised in london
mary crawford something of a cross
between elizabeth bennett
and lady susan henry crawford
a flirt who may charm the reader but
cannot succeed in charming fanny
he hatches a plan to make her fall in
love with him and is appropriately
punished by
falling in love with her himself and by
surprising both himself
and the reader with his potential for
transformation
cassandra begged jane to let henry
win fanny's handed marriage but she had
other plans
and fanny marries her own secret love
cousin edmond
mansfield park features searching
debates on
the morality of acting the value of
formal prayer
and the settled versus the mobile way of
life
but i think its most remarkable feature
is that austin sustains our interest
in a heroine who unlike every young
woman she'd previously scripted
almost never speaks i wonder
sometimes if fanny's silence in the face
of people
and events that swirl around her
constant reminders of her dependence
reflects something of what austin
herself experienced
during eight years when she seldom held
a pen in her hands
mansfield park was published in 1814
a year after pride and prejudice as if
conscious that it would not be
so well liked austin kept a bemused
record
of the opinions expressed by friends and
relations
her professional success was
increasingly known in her family circle
but was by no means universal knowledge
among her acquaintance
mansfield park she notes mr egerton the
publisher
praised it for its morality and for
being so equal a composition
no weak parts meanwhile a hampshire
neighbor must have unwittingly confessed
that
she thought sense and sensibility and
pride and prejudice
downright nonsense but expected to like
mansfield park better and having
finished the first volume
flattered herself she had got through
the worst
between 1814 and 1815
austin drafted emma perhaps her single
greatest masterpiece
written at the height of her powers and
again from the security of settled life
in chattan
a superficial acquaintance with austin's
canon
detects the sameness of the courtship
driven plot
but even a cursory reading of emma next
to its predecessor mansfield
park or its successor persuasion reveals
the exuberance with which austin
relished a new challenge
emma is everything fannie price is not
as you can see here she's more often in
motion
she's born to wealth and power she's
talkative and extroverted
she's admired by many including herself
like elizabeth bennett she's a confident
young woman
who must confront her own errors but
emma's education
unfolds in a series of revelations that
are
drawn out through a highly intricate
plot and she's also distinct
in that through the masterful
manipulation of point of view
her overconfidence is exposed to us
from the start this is what generates
the delightful humor
of her story if elizabeth is written as
something like a friend to the reader
emma is a beloved niece
one whose progress we chart with bemused
affection
from a stance of greater experience
if we look on emma's progress from the
vantage point of more mature knowledge
austin herself was growing into the role
of loving advisor
to her nephews and nieces she cautioned
her niece fanny
not to be overly charmed by charisma or
wit in a suitor
but to study private character she
encouraged her niece anna
an aspiring writer to value precision
over flair and to be content with a
narrow focus
to find the drama in a modest setting
and to avoid phrases like vortex of
dissipation
by early 1816 when emma was published
austin was herself composing a drama in
which modesty and patience
are the central virtues in its opening
chapters
austin describes the chastened mindset
of her aging heroine
and elliot is 27 and verging on
confirmed spinsterhood
she had been forced into prudence in her
youth
she learned romance as she grew older
the natural sequel to an unnatural
beginning
in her personal copy of the novel
cassandra wrote in the margin
dear dear jane this deserves to be
written
in letters of gold as if these words
hold a special key to jane austen's mind
and heart
and i think the notion of learning
romance is the reason
the belief that happy endings emerge
from the quality of attention
we bestow on outwardly undramatic people
as well as commonplace moments and
settings
is an insight that explains the lasting
power and lasting relevance
of austin's fiction
originally titled the elliots and
published as persuasion
this last finished work is shorter than
austin's earlier novels
and in some ways more muted in tone
she was beginning to feel unwell
she had the disposable income to buy
back the manuscript for northinger abbey
from crosby's publishing house but she
made only minimal revisions
and set it aside perhaps a sign of her
diminished energy
in may she visited a spa for refreshment
may of 1816 that is and later that
summer
entertaining house guests while
cassandra was away
expressed with a sense of wistfulness
that
composition seems to me impossible with
a head full of joints of mutton
and doses of rhubarb she must have been
thinking of sanditon
a story set in an up-and-coming resort
town that appears to be among other
things a satire on those who frequent
spas
and suffer from imaginary illness
sickness is a dangerous indulgence at my
time of life
she wrote with a chin up attitude to her
niece fanny
nevertheless she was too unwell to draft
more than 12 chapters of sanditon
austin's niece caroline later described
a touching scene from around this time
aunt jane used often to lie down after
dinner
my grandmother herself was frequently on
the sofa
sometimes in the afternoon sometimes in
the evening
at no fixed period of the day she had
not bad health for her age
and she worked often for hours in the
garden and naturally wanted rest
afterwards
there was only one sofa in the room and
aunt jane laid upon
three chairs which she arranged for
herself i think she had a pillow
but it never looked comfortable
she called it her sofa and even when the
other was unoccupied
she never took it i often asked her how
she could like the chairs best
and i suppose i worried her into telling
me the reason of her choice
which was that if she ever used the sofa
grandma would be leaving it for her
and would not lie down as she did now
whenever she felt inclined
i can never decide if this reflects an
excess of good manners
or a sense of distance between mother
and daughter
or perhaps those are two sides of a
single coin
as it happened as spring advanced jane's
letters confess that she's increasingly
confined to bed
she suffers fevers back pain and a
growing fatigue
after periods of seeming convalescence
she would experience
bouts of pain that belied the notion of
progress
what was her illness for many years the
suggestion was addison's disease
which is a tuberculosis of the adrenal
glands
but a more recent hypothesis points to
some form of lymphoma
we'll never be sure the letters from
march and april
of 1817 brim with gratitude for the
devoted care of her family and the
buoyant expectation of improvement
it's interesting to wonder if in this
attitude
austin was consciously crafting a
fiction for her first and last audience
her family circle for in april
unbeknownst even to cassandra
she drew up an unwitnessed will
a month later the sisters took lodgings
in winchester
to consult an experienced physician
there
by june jane was apparently too weak
to take up her pen at all but words were
her connection with life
on july 15 she dictated to cassandra
a poem 24 lines on the subject of the
annual winchester horse races
remarkable how she continued to turn her
attention outward
to the life around her and early on the
morning of july 18th
she died with her head in cassandra's
lap
her last surviving letter to a nephew
concludes with a poignant reflection of
what this keen observer
saw and felt when she turned her eyes on
herself
god bless you my dear edward if ever you
are ill
may you be as tenderly nursed as i have
been
may the same blessed alleviations of
anxious sympathizing friends
be yours and may you possess as i dare
say you will
the greatest blessing of all in the
consciousness of not being
unworthy of their love i could not feel
this
your very affectionate aunt j.a
she was buried in winchester cathedral
the place marked with a black marble
plaque
and an inscription that cites the
extraordinary endowments of her mind as
just one of many virtues
with cassandra's help henry composed a
brief
biographical notice for their sister and
arranged for northanger abbey
to be published with persuasion by the
end of the year the pairing is odd
but also apt persuasion
her last completed novel and featuring a
heroine
subdued by painful experience alongside
northanger abbey
scarcely touched since austin had
drafted it 20 years earlier
with her most naive heroine and
certainly her most ebullient narrator
the comparison shows us that austin
never wrote half-heartedly
never wrote with less than mastery of
her craft and never stopped changing and
growing
fifty years later the nephew to whom
austin addressed her last
letter james edward austin lee would
compose a more detailed memoir which
seems to have catalyzed interest in her
work
both sales and critical commentary were
modest before the turn of the century
her popularity with ordinary readers as
opposed to fellow novelists
was boosted by the emergence of
paperback editions in the mid 20th
century
and since then she has proved herself
worthy of a very rare honor
an assured place in the canon of great
books in the academy
and the lasting devotion of those who
read only
for pleasure in the words of northanger
abbey
and what are you reading miss oh it is
only a novel replies the young lady
while she lays down her book with
affected indifference or
momentary shame it is only cecilia
or camilla or belinda or in short
only some work in which the greatest
powers of the mind are displayed
in which the most thorough knowledge of
human nature the happiest delineation of
its varieties
the liveliest effusions of wit and humor
are conveyed to the world
in the best chosen language
given her current fame another
adaptation of
sense and sensibility or emma might seem
ordinary
nothing special what are your plans this
evening you might be asked
oh i'm only attending the jane austen
cca
i'm confident however that those of us
who take a closer look
will continue to prize a quiet
exuberance
that belongs to only jane austen thank
you
thank you dr murphy we now have time for
some q a
if you have a question please make your
way to one of the microphones in the
aisle
hi dr murphy um i was just curious
if we have access to the original draft
of eleanor and marianne
and if we see any significant
differences between that draft and sense
and sensibility which was written after
all of her
heartache we do not have access to that
first draft
and i believe it's on the basis mainly
of
internal evidence in the finished sense
and sensibility although i think also
from
one or two brief remarks in her letters
that we
are pretty confident it was originally
in the epistolary style and then revised
but we do not have that draft the only
um of her published novels her finished
novels
the only manuscript that survives is
interestingly
uh the concluding two chapters of
persuasion uh which she cancelled and
rewrote
so what we have is what she threw out
and it's quite interesting to see
what she wrote the first time but of her
finished work that's that's the only
manuscript in her hand that survives
all right so uh in recent years some uh
criticisms of the economist adam smith
have been that when he wrote wealth of
nations
he had this maidservant who's really
taking care of him the entire time so of
course he's going to write this
incredible economic theory about
capitalism because he doesn't have to do
anything
uh at least reflecting on the quote like
a mind lively and at ease can do
with seeing nothing could you see future
literary criticisms of jane austen
appearing basically because as you said
in the
when she was at the peak of her powers
she was allowed to write the entire day
and it didn't really seem to be that
there was much of a
struggle or intersectional narrative
being applied towards her life at that
time
um if i understand your question is it's
concerning
future novelists or concerning austin
herself so concerning austin herself
could you see people criticizing her
currently or in the future because when
she was writing that was kind of all she
had to do like
of course she's going to produce all
these works but was there any real
struggle involved at that time
she um you see that critique of her
work sometimes of her fiction where uh
you have
a way of life you know mrs bennett both
her her daughters have nothing to do in
the kitchen
that that's all taken care of um
when austin and her sister and mother
lived at chotton cottage they did have
some help in the kitchen but that did
not mean that they were
uninvolved um but i think that
i mean jane austen grew up in a family
where
she was accustomed to working and making
a contribution
where everyone with an able pair of
hands was accustomed to working and
making a contribution
and she and her sister and mother worked
something out where
they sort of agreed to shoulder a burden
um
with a loving sense of of what jane um
jane's vocation so uh she certainly was
not
distant from the reality of labor and
the way that labor
supports leisure and creativity uh she
actually befriended actually
in her will she left everything to
cassandra
except uh 50 pounds to her brother henry
whose bank had failed
and 50 pounds to a servant of a
sister-in-law
for whom she had a friendship she
maintained
an ongoing correspondence a very
friendly correspondence with
the woman who was the governess at her
brother edward's
home in kent so she seems to have had a
great sympathy for
working women and i think she was
kind of closer to that reality than we
realize if we only read her
her published work
i know you said that uh there weren't
any satisfactory
versions of mansfield park on film i'm
curious why do you think that is
is there something about it that's
difficult to adapt or
i think so um and i should have one
thing about austin that is very easy to
adapt is her her dialogue
she writes wonderful dialogue and she
has a wonderful ear for voice
and for those little inflections of uh
and mannerisms of of speech that
give such a lively sense of character so
in a lot of
film adaptations you'll find the
dialogue almost word for word what
you'll find in the novels
but as i said fanny price almost never
speaks
and it's difficult i think on film and
not impossible certainly but i think
it's difficult to give a sense of the
drama going on in the mind um
with so little being said and and
in some ways um the liveliest adaptation
of mansfield park that i've
seen makes of fanny price
a an entirely different character and
the movie makers seem to have
sort of decided to replace fanny price
with a picture of the young jane austen
which is interesting but it's not fanny
price so
her silence and her um kind of passivity
her weakness
even when she's pushed or pressed she
often doesn't wish to respond and
even for readers of the novel that can
feel frustrating
so translating that to film is maybe
especially frustrating
you're welcome hi thank you for your
talk
i was just wondering how common was it
at that time for women to be authors
and what kind of obstacles does that
present to austin in her career
it was i don't know if you would call it
common but common enough that austin was
familiar with the published work
certainly of other female novelists
the obstacle was leisure
so even if austin had let's say married
harris big wither and become quite a
wealthy
woman living a comfortable life her
duties as the head of the household
would probably have prevented her from
having that time to
sit down and draft and revise
women often didn't publish under their
own names so none of austin's works was
published in her lifetime
under her name but that didn't mean that
women weren't interested in professional
success and
and uh and the independence that that
could provide so
there were models but they were not many
and as you could see austin had to sort
of forge a way of life that would
support
her work uh and that was sometimes
difficult to do
um in previous lectures it had been said
that
jane austen didn't necessarily write
sorry she took when she was writing her
novels
she took for granted her social class
and
that the novels weren't necessarily to
like depict
that would would you say that that
is an accurate description of how she
wrote in regards to social class
especially considering the fact that um
at least it seems like in her younger
years and then after her father's death
her social status wasn't
necessarily secure
i think that she took the class system
if we want to call it that
uh for granted has has been said a
couple of times
um and i i don't think she was setting
out to
reform it um or to
question it um in any kind of radical
way um her own life was and this is not
often
i think sometimes easy to overlook she
wrote about
um
a social uh way of life
that was a degree or two above her own
and uh it's a way of life she would have
been familiar with for example at her
brother edward's home
and or at harris big withers home or she
moved in a circle
where this way of life could be known to
her and could become familiar to her but
it wasn't
her way of life
and i think that in if she chooses not
to make that
a central tension in her novels you know
the difference between
what a woman like jane austen has to do
with her duties and daily
responsibilities
versus what a woman like elizabeth
bennett has to do it's a question that
in some sense uh doesn't come up or
comes up in subtle quiet ways that
that can be probed but that don't really
cry out for attention
the one novel where she does take i
think a closer and maybe more critical
look at england's social system is her
last work persuasion
and it's interesting to wonder what she
might have done in sanditon but
we really can't we can't be too sure but
in persuasion you have a kind of
dialogue between
the landed gentry as exemplified by
sir walter elliott who is a really kind
of
comical but sad failure
of a baronet and uh and and the navy
and austin was loved the navy was very
loyal to the navy and
very proud of her brothers who are naval
officers
uh and there you have a sort of
merit-based social system
that in persuasion austin seems to find
very refreshing
and positive so i wouldn't say that
social critique is absent from her work
but um
it's muted and i i certainly think that
she um
you know she's not she's not a thorough
going radical egalitarian
she knows that roles can be
while limiting also very supportive
of the relationships that we establish
and
the work that we do if you like in
society
hi so you mentioned that pride and
prejudice was originally titled first
impressions
so i was wondering if you could speak a
little bit more on that why was the
reason
for the change in title and who did this
and then
why pride and prejudice versus first
impressions
um i think that her publisher i'm not
100 sure on this but i think
that her publisher suggested the title
pride and prejudice and i think that was
based on
kind of the style uh it was doing well
at the time
austin herself does not seem to be have
been a great writer of titles and
uh her siblings changed the title she
had in mind she drafted things with
titles that um
you know should just use the name the
elliott's susan and uh
emma um
for why first impressions uh i think
because
um both darcy and elizabeth bennett uh
are too reliant on their first
impressions and austin was always very
interested in
um
in a society and this builds a little
bit on the last question
where um mannered behavior was very
important
and there was a kind of decorum and
structure to what you could say and do
in society
it can be difficult to read between the
lines and
and first you have to make a judgment
based on what people
say and do in society and and often two
people who are going to be engaged to be
married would never have been alone
together
they would have seen each other entirely
in in social and socially controlled
settings
so the um the importance of looking past
first impressions is i think what she's
really driving at in that novel
we have time for one more question
thank you for your time tonight dr
murphy um so from your discussion
it seems that austin had a really
special relationship with
several members of her family especially
her sister and just considering that
there are several
um sister pairs and close female
friendships in her books
can you just talk a little bit about how
hers relationship with her sister might
have impacted those
relationships in the books they were
very very close
um as i said when cassandra was away
jane had to write
she had to put down her thoughts to
cassandra you can see that in the
comment
her mother made when they were girls uh
jane's devotion to cassandra
i think the fact that they had both
known the sadness of perhaps
anticipating marriage uh certainly
cassandra had anticipated a marriage and
jane i think had at least begun to do so
and and
and uh um letting go of that
uh must have bound them closer together
and they would have anticipated i mean
by the time
uh jane died i mean they would have
anticipated growing old together
and
this was as i say it's a it's a social
world where
uh you know the behavior at a card party
or um
in a sitting room uh or at a meal has a
kind of
script to it and the number of people
with whom you would share your
unvarnished
from the heart emotions and feelings and
words would be
would be very few and cassandra was i
think that person for jane and i'm sure
jane was that person for cassandra
sibling relationships in general are um
are prized in her novels
again we tend to think of them as the
novels about courtship and marriage but
um they're really novels about societies
and communities and siblings are sort of
our first society
jane jane loved that please join me in
thanking dr murphy
you